[Musik]
es ist Freitag der 30 September 2022
in der südukrainischen Region saporicia
wird ein Konvoi mit privaten Fahrzeugen
angegriffen
mindestens 30 Menschen sterben bei einem
Raketenangriff der russischen Armee mit
einer perfiden Taktik nicht eine Rakete
schlägt ein es sind drei Geschosse
zeitlich versetzt auf dasselbe Ziel
der Konvoi wollte sich gerade auf den
Weg machen der erste Raketeneinschlag
erfolgte 8:15 Uhr nach 20 bis 30 Minuten
der nächste und nach einem weiteren
Intervall der dritte alle auf den Markt
offensichtlich wollten die Russen so
viele Ukrainer wie möglich töten
splitterraketen eingesetzt dieser
Raketentyp verursacht hohe Verluste
durch Granatsplitter
die Ukraine in Angst Zivilisten als Ziel
und Rettungskräfte dafür beschießen die
russischen Streitkräfte gezielt eine
Wohngegend nicht nur einmal sondern
zweimal
das zweite Mal wenn Rettungskräfte
eingetroffen sind um auch sie zu töten
oder ein Krankenhaus in der Nähe wird
beschossen
mykoleiew am 29 juli erst trifft es eine
Bushaltestelle und Wohnhäuser in der
Gegend fünf Menschen sterben sieben
Verletzte kommen ins Krankenhaus
zwei Tage später wird dann das
Krankenhaus beschossen am 1 August
zerstört von russischen Raketen
double Tab Strike doppelschläge zu heißt
diese Terror Taktik
die würde von der armee-führung des
Kremls befohlen ist der Nies monastirski
Innenminister der Ukraine überzeugt
double Tab strikes gebe es inzwischen
täglich
allein am 10 und 11 oktober haben die
Russen 222 Objekte beschossen bei 99%
waren es doppelschläge und fast
ausschließlich gegen zivile Ziele von
den 222 Objekten waren nur zwei
militärische nur zwei
die OSZE die Organisation für Sicherheit
und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
veröffentlichte bereits am 13 April
einen Bericht über Verstöße gegen
internationale Menschenrechte über
Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit
der Bericht beschreibt auch double Tab
attacks ein Beispiel ist dieser
russische Angriff auf hakif am ersten
März
dazu heißt es
nach dem Rettungskräfte angekommen waren
nach fünf bis sieben Minuten gab es
einen zweiten Schlag mit einer ähnlichen
Rakete die das Gebäude traf dies
impliziert dass die Retter und die
Personen die durch den ersten Angriff
verwundet wurden absichtlich ins Visier
genommen wurden
im Bundestag sprechen wir mit Roderich
kieserwetter Verteidigungspolitiker der
Union Russlands Terror durch double Tab
Attacken aber seit Jahren System
russland hat leider diese Methode
bereits in Syrien praktiziert das wird
bewusst gemacht um Angst und Terror zu
spüren also das gesamte Gebilde zielt
darauf ab die Verunsicherung zu erhöhen
und auch den Menschen die bereit sind zu
helfen und zu unterstützen die letzte
Hoffnung zu nehmen dass sie mit ihren
mit ihrer Hilfsbereitschaft noch etwas
bewirken es ist eine Methode die
furchtbar ist und die vor das
internationale Kriegsverbrechertribunal
gehört
ostguter Syrien bis März 2018 in der
Hand der gegner des syrischen
Präsidenten Assad durch wochenlange
Luftangriffe werden die Rebellen
geschlagen auch mit Hilfe des Kremls der
das Assad-Regime unterstützt und mit der
russischen Luftwaffe massiv bombardiert
auch hier setzen die Russen ihre Terror
Taktik der Double Tab strikes ein ohne
Rücksicht auf die Zivilbevölkerung
zurück bleiben zerstörte Städte
[Musik]
when the planes return wenn die
Flugzeuge wiederkehren die inwashington
ansässige Syrische
Menschenrechtsorganisation Syria justice
and accountability Center hat double Tab
strikes in Syrien untersucht von den 58
analysierten Angriffen wurden 21 von der
russischen Luftwaffe ausgeführt
in Washington erreiche ich die Anwältin
nessmer bashi die Autorin der Studie
man kann mit Sicherheit sagen dass
Syrien eine Art Übungsgelände für die
russischen Streitkräfte war in
Verbindung mit den syrischen Truppen all
diese Methoden die wir in Syrien gesehen
haben sehen wir jetzt in der Ukraine und
das ist schon ziemlich entmutigend umso
mehr müssen wir uns für die universelle
Gerichtsbarkeit einsetzen wenn die Zeit
gekommen ist die Täter umfassend zur
Rechenschaft zu ziehen
einer der Täter ist er der Befehlshaber
der russischen Luftwaffe armee-general
Sergej surowikin er führte Russlands
Truppen in Syrien gilt als besonders
brutal und rücksichtslos ist
verantwortlich für zahlreiche
Luftschläge gegen syrische Zivilisten
dafür überreicht Präsident Putin seinem
general 2017 den Orden hält Russlands
und nun Anfang Oktober ernennt Putin
surowikin zum Befehlshaber der
russischen Truppen in der Ukraine kaum
im Amt befiehlt er massive Luftschläge
gegen Kiew und andere Städte
surowikin war Kommandeur im
Tschetschenienkrieg als Moskau
islamistische Rebellen bekämpfte und die
Hauptstadt großen
die russische Teilrepublik
Tschetschenien wird heute von Diktator
ramsam kadurov beherrscht Putin
befördert ihn Anfang Oktober zum
Generaloberst den dritthöchsten Rang in
der russischen Armee
kardiurow ist für zahlreiche
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
verantwortlich doch für Putin offenbar
der richtige Mann
kadirows Truppen gelten als besonders
brutal im Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen
die Ukraine
Mario Pohl Putins Truppen haben die
Stadt dem Erdboden gleichgemacht statt
sie einzunehmen aus Sicht des
ukrainischen Innenministers aus einem
ganz bestimmten Grund
es ist die Taktik der verbrannten Erde
früher wurde sie angewendet wenn sich
Truppen zurückzogen damit der Feind nur
zerstörtes Land erobert Russland findet
diese Taktik umgekehrt an beim Angriff
die Russen verstehen dass Ihnen dieses
Land niemals gehören wird sie verstehen
dass Milliarden von Dollar gebraucht
werden um die zerstörten Häuser wieder
aufzubauen
brutale Zerstörung Angst und Schrecken
immer wieder schlagen Raketen in
ukrainische Wohngebäude ein auch nachts
Zivilisten werden im Schlaf ermordet die
Überlebenden sind fassungslos
das ist Terrorismus dem kann man nicht
entkommen
es gibt nichts in der Gegend keine
Industrie kein Militär keine
Rüstungsfirmen warum bombardieren Sie
uns warum
Ukraine ist Präsident selenski macht
sich keine Illusionen über die Absicht
des Krems sie versuchen uns zu zerstören
und uns vom Erdboden zu tilgen schreibt
er auf telegram
die Taktik des Terrors könnte aufgehen
meint Sicherheitspolitiker kieserwetter
wenn der Westen vor Putin zurückweicht
es wird ihm dann gelingen wenn wir nicht
mehr bereit sind die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wenn wir nicht
durchhaltefähig sind wenn wir nicht die
psychische und physische Kraft haben das
auszuhalten was da noch auf uns zukommt
deswegen müssen wir unsere Bevölkerung
auf die noch absehbaren Eskalationen
vorbereiten und stärken wir müssen
selber resilienter werden
widerstandsfähiger und das bedeutet noch
zwei drei Jahre den Gürtel enger
schnallen und vor allen Dingen uns auf
Grausamkeiten gefasst machen
Kiew 17 Oktober ukrainische Polizisten
beschießen kamikazedonen russischer
Terror aus der Luft mit Drohnen aus dem
Iran die neueste Eskalation im
Angriffskrieg
die Ukraine dokumentieren alle Angriffe
der Russen genau das Ergebnis eindeutig
seit Kriegsbeginn wurden 300
militärische Ziele der Ukraine
angegriffen und 22.000 zivile